[Music]
hello
good morning gamers early today
how are y'all doing this fun morning
yes can you hear me all right near the
game
everything good okay let's continue
should we wake him up oh he woke himself
up
dude you should get one of those airline
pillows
you'll be fine uh this is always issue
when i stop playing
and i'm like wait what was i doing so we
unlocked him
did i buy the stuff i needed
i don't know
dude people mad at me not using the
grenade launcher like
i save it for the bosses obviously get
out of here
people mad at me for everything in this
game like damn
so many people complaining i don't use
that
automatic pistol like i know it's
automatic but i use it as a
semi and it's like well
i want to say bullets i don't want to
waste them
why waves bullets
idiots all right
i don't remember maybe i've gotten worse
at gaming man
i don't remember people being so [ __ ]
pissy
in the comments on these but there's a
lot of uh love as well which i
appreciate thank you guys
i'm gonna be glowing playing others so
okay got a long way to go
let's go apparently there's a long way
to go
i don't want to fight heisenberg i got
to be completely honest with you guys
you seem cool
ah watch
i know this is a bit late in the game
but i kind of want to see if i can
fix these controls because like it's so
awful amy
no where's movement speed
maybe it's this that i need to do no
that would be awkward see if this one's
spider
bit clunky
[Music]
give me two seconds
yeah yeah now we ain't good
miranda thinks we're nothing but
children
oh she doesn't care for us no
she's long lost all her humanity god
it's so dark i can't see anything
or do i have to cry i don't give a [ __ ]
about your family drama
i think i figured out the plot
it hasn't been spoiled or anything but
we could be wrong
miranda is clearly our girlfriend right
because we haven't seen [ __ ] all of her
and she was acting all suss
why do i smell like gas or something bro
don't hit me oh he's just trying to do
his job
can we ignore these guys
how you doing
vote miranda out
man they're just trying to mine and [ __ ]
also why are we putting our baby into
that
thing without hesitating
guess we got no other options eh
all right i think this
should be their final episode
well let's see this looks like a
fighting ground
maybe we should place pancakes
i see the thing there but i'll pick it
up later
nice
oh gosh i didn't see you mate
i had to do it to him hold up let me
reel up bro [ __ ] blocking
just kill them in time
that's not gas in my building
hopefully i won't die if i start
tripping out
let me know this is very faint
kind of like someone use hairspray or
something
it's red all right um
crystal it's still red uh
i'm sure this stuff upstairs actually
how do we not have a flashlight at this
point get a
gotta check the corners for the jump
scare
when going through tight quarters
there's a bird cage by the entrance
isn't that what they use in the mines to
have to blow this up probably yeah
check if there's gas that's ironic
give me that i want all the money i want
to upgrade all my guns
all right i clearly missed some stuff
and i actually need it at this point of
the game
there it is and there was a bird cage
or the entrance there you are thanks
guys
hopefully shotgun ammo
yes nice excellent
it's blue now hooray
which one goes down there you go
i think this is the for now but who
knows
let me just check where that smell has
come from
c
right here
they're always working on buildings
outside they're probably painting or
something
it's really strong
am i tripping out
i don't know [ __ ] weird
i'm losing it
give me that whoa
place of junk
all right give me all the loot
yeah give me that yeah give me the
it's from the mines yeah probably
[Music]
oh i said the drill box
don't do it to me oh we should probably
use a name here
but they put this
another it's funny how they can hurt you
and i kind of like that
like the mines do nothing
are you not dead yet
oh god am i actually
we're fine we're fine
hold up can i walk here yeah oh this
damn
i need them to die i need them to die
[ __ ]
don't hurt me okay won that
nice
i guess we still have the propeller mini
boss thing right
running low on stuff
finally getting used to my pancakes at
lions
explosive protein pancakes very good
you know let's place is what i wanted to
do like starting off youtube
and playing horror games it's kind of
reminiscent and fun to
still be able to do it
uh and also seeing you guys with the
same
excitement because like i remember
watching let's plays and being so hyped
for a new episode coming up
every day uh where do i shoot it
there it's fun to
give that experience back
are there more than one yeah
but let's place was uh such a small
thing
before
that was [ __ ] huge everyone's doing
it
how do i get there
times change me
i think horror games especially is fun
to watch someone else play right
oh i almost missed this one
remember being 13 to 40 and watching i'm
23 now man
thanks for sticking around man
and new happy wheels let's play coming
right up
hell yeah
is the quality better today i i upped
the bitrate a little bit but i was
lagging so i don't know
i just looked at uh jack and mark's
let's play and they look so [ __ ]
clean i was like [ __ ] my quality
is actually back
i didn't realize because it looks so
good for me it looks amazing
all right that's got to be a boss coming
out
hey boot is back the best supportive
character
thank you for always being here the map
of course
which i've been helped getting so much
help from i see you
you got to get rid of this scrap first
let's try it anyway
nope it's literally just pushing it
let me check here first well actually it
would make more sense if
this is the hidden bit
don't scare me now
window frame which is around the corner
door frame and that's where small thing
another mold [ __ ] how many molds
does a man need sheep
all right
i used to think it also was so cool to
watch people play horror games
that weren't scared at all
i remember in the beginning i was like
oh [ __ ]
i wish i could be like that clearly
didn't work out
i gotta shoot the thing this is a quick
time thing yeah there you go
i got sucked propeller boss oh he's not
gonna be happy about that
this looks like a fighting ground right
that was close
no all right check this out oh
i see
give me give me
oh i [ __ ] right in front of me
scariest game i played uh not this one
seriously i can knife it from here
there we go
which game did it seem like i was most
scared playing probably the first
amnesia honestly that was heavy to play
like oh oh thank god i'm done with this
part
i can stop now
oh i thought i died [ __ ]
am i supposed to climb up here let's
check down first
the first bioshock spoke maybe well it's
really scary in the start
yeah but then it doesn't get scary at
all anymore
here we go oh thank god we were blue
soon she'll start her ceremony with your
rubbers if that happens
it's all over for your kid
and for the whole village but don't
worry
i'll stop it i'll use rose
to kill miranda
poor papa you're the only one who
doesn't see your kid's
power take rose
typical of parents i'd like to see you
try
i think they've taken her already bro
most fun game i played was probably one
like ib or something like that one of
the
[ __ ] sake more molds i gotta do with
these
nothing how dare you
this is red wait what's over here
excuse me excuse me matt there's a
ladder later
no wait what how do i get there is that
a hidden wall
what
explain this to me
oh very confused oh it's up there
isn't it yeah
ah there's more there's always more even
thanks megan
hopefully we have a ton of money now i
don't think we do
but hopefully
we're on the final floor now right yeah
come on
surprise this elevator is able to carry
this man
is this the last one this is the big
shot
hello oh yes
wait you can what is this oh it looked
like it gave me no mind
power on the gun for sure oh god and
we're broke now
but we can sell stuff
come on give me money wait
that's combinable
looks like something used to be attached
to it
but what
i have magnum ammo oh nice
none of these crystals right your coin
okay we have six decay used to be alive
it's 80k
can we combine it with something a good
deal if i say so myself
oh we can make the the ball that's cool
no we have nothing oh yes
yeah maybe the mold
securing goods is more important than
anything
and until next we meet
where's the mold area oh my god it
goes away
can we go there is that
it
if it's just looking window shop away
an interesting selection let's get some
shotgun ammo
don't think we need hang gun
i think we're good
thank you for your patronage where is it
[Music]
hey
okay
tell me to spend all the money can i go
down here oh i can
oh let's go to the mold
which floor is that on
engine room oh gosh
no it's on the second floor
i feel like it was close to the elevator
at some point this is where we were
is that in here maybe
i actually have no idea
b4 in the dark hallway really
sorry what's the right way
creepy hallway hopefully nothing
respawns
don't kill me just want them all
come on put the sweets in plain
[ __ ] [ __ ]
run close to him is he dead
he glitched out you okay buddy
you'll get it together thank you
green light maybe it's here
i wish it was on the map this is red
this room
oh nice
i'm walking in circles now
i actually have no idea
okay map this is this okay
that room is red so maybe let's check
that out
i'm sorry it looks like there's a door
here
what
we must be close to it this room is red
you might want to check it out while
we're here
uh another thing with let's plays i did
the same station song i got a lot of
questions about
it's just i always did it
and i think it started in dead space 2
is it coming through yeah
ow
don't cover it
uh when i played dead space 2 i recorded
that over two days
but then that was a month worth of
videos i would upload 10 minutes a day
that's what people did back in the day
but now there's such a high demand for
content it's like oh if you haven't
finished the game in like
the first two days and people stop
caring
because of streaming
people finish the game so here finally
uh so quickly no one wants to wait for
parts instead
all right let's make a key mold
thank you
because i was uh i was in school at the
time i did let's plays
so for me to record that i just did the
videos and then edited them obviously
and
uh whoa
[ __ ] sake yeah just focus on school in
between
can't do that now i got more time though
which is nine
not complaining at all
okay where's the labyrinth puzzle though
there it is
now that's heisenberg's key which we
have now
i actually don't know where that
labyrinth is
have we not seen it it's coming up later
i don't remember seeing it
yeah it might be later right
room next to elevator okay thanks
finally it's red over here what is this
switch
let me do this already
oh what is this
oh don't mind if i do
these guys are gonna come alive for sure
god damn it don't hurt me
drill people i think there's so many
drills anyway
we got flashbangs maybe i should start
using them
where are they
can't i bind them
project us for a grenade launcher oh
oh
it just sounded so useless i'm like i'm
gonna focus on that machine
l two plus x
now it's a flashback
hello is it oh god
how is he alive what the [ __ ]
it's fine
more money please
kind of take my time here sorry now
we're near the end
is jack in the chat i keep missing him
medical log revitalization surgery
this is my 18th attempt
the subject is oscar the stable boy 20
years old
he fell down the well while drunk bodies
in good condition
oh poor oscar
justin complete
[Applause]
it's progressing even faster than before
it seems upping the ratio of metal
maybe we shouldn't work with heisenberg
now to pass a current through the
brainstem using
6600 volts come on
it has to work this time
uh-huh did it yes
wonderful my creations
at last i'll get that
[ __ ] yet
[Applause]
ending recording this is why you
shouldn't be creative not everyone
should be
uh what yes
hell yes oh long boy now
let me quit that i want to see it oh so
long
so strong three shots [ __ ] me
okay why did we go here i just missed
this area somehow
uh uh i forgot i forgot what chad said
where do i need to go
i've also missed something in this room
it cannot be oh my [ __ ] god
plain sight [ __ ]
now it's blue hell yeah
next to the duke okay that's
this way i know that because i don't
need a map
[ __ ] where am i i'm lost it's so dark
and scary in here i don't like it
maps are for
let me get the key
whoa you're huge
i ain't finding that um
present present number two
okay how do i kill this [ __ ] all right
he's dead
[ __ ] can you stop moving
oh god there we go
you're useless
please die thank god
big boy perfect mechanical heart
is that what you guys said you can
combine
no you lied as always
liar smire friends don't lie
yeah don't need a map clearly don't need
a map look at me not needing a map
[ __ ]
okay maybe oh of course
of course of course oh another red room
that we left
please feed that right door please
please
i remember being here if that helps
anyone
okay let's think we need to go back to
the duke
it's over here isn't it
that's a room we never enter
we check that out really quick
did this one no we entered it we just
didn't loot everything
what is there something missing here
oh there you are
hey rich
okay we're done here go back up
clearly i'm missing something here but
hey what are you gonna do
uh where's the search
[ __ ] this place is confusing
at least somebody we can go through
there
okay
this is it
definitely feeling confident
here we go [ __ ]
have i not used all of this
should i use heisenberg's quarters key
does that progress the story or no
let's use this now what's going on in
here
oh we definitely want to use this okay
hey guys what's up
oh cool you can shoot him in the back of
the head
not panicking not panicking got plenty
of time
not panicking got plenty of time
oh controlled baby
that's sorry that ah there's one more
oh he's all over the place
don't hit him thank you
thank you all right man's gotta have a
lot of loot
i did not waste like oh my god it's all
[ __ ]
no i did not do all of that for nothing
stop don't be blue okay
what am i missing the giant chest
perhaps okay
oh could this be
hammer it's too heavy to use
okay cool we've done everything here now
i just need to find my way back to the
duke
which honestly i know exactly where to
go that's the elevator right
um just gotta
just gotta just gotta
just gotta how
it's too heavy to use for two light gear
right yeah right all the crap i'm
carrying
that's definitely has man i mean i don't
have any dude
this guy just got gotta
shh okay got it i got it my brain's got
it
it's locked it's locked in my brain
watch this 100 accuracy you go here
and go here 100 accuracy
and go up the stairs wherever they are
100 accuracy coming up no map needed
gang
no map gang yeah
and it's got a huh
and then
what's a door and what is it
ah okay got it 100 accuracy
100 accuracy yes
i'm so smart holy [ __ ] largest brain in
town
no i don't want to fly anymore i i'm no
we're not
no no no i am running out of ammo
okay you hear me i did nothing
flashbangs are terrible
okay uh that's fine because i have
uh no that's not what i want to do
change ammo thanks for letting me take
my time thanks
there you go and i'm normal hey no no no
no we don't do that ronnie
let me reload
come on [ __ ]
[ __ ] your armor oh [ __ ] he's mad that's
fine
honestly i get angry too sometimes
it's okay it's okay
i hit you i hit you
stop blocking so lame
hey you you fell for my huh
okay now we don't don't block
only i can block
how are you still alive i like killed
you billion times
what my patience
is running thin here bro
thank you all right
some money for the road i'll take it
thank you thank you
[ __ ] where was i he totally threw me out
okay at last
the duke we got it all
kind of worked out in a weird way
my
oh sell oh shell
oh i'm ready to work hard with this no
no i'm more than happy gonna ghost
it goes my chat now i'm too rich for you
i want power on the shot oh we can max
it out
all finished you know what
i don't know if i should do that
how much more reload speed that's our
cowards
max shotgun baby max shotgun gang
securing goods is more important than
anything
anything my friend can you sell me some
shotgun ammo please
oh excellent choice
huh oh broken so poor gang
until next week
okay
[Music]
hold up hold up we still have the puzzle
i just realized you guys know where it
is
i have no [ __ ] clue
because we have the ball right i did i
didn't make the ball right
there you are
right outside of duke's room so it's
here
down here i jump
it's here
yes thanks
well this one looks cool
i like it oh did i fail what's going on
oh
okay no
yes okay
okay and then it goes i gotta get back
back
can i not change my camera angle uh okay
i guess
oh
oh i moved the tram as well oh that's
cool
okay [ __ ] i can't see anything
uh uh yeah
oh try and try and try it all works out
no the tram had a holy name i didn't see
it [ __ ]
cool this one is definitely trickier
than the other ones [ __ ]
okay yes
[ __ ] you tram how dare you
going for it
okay it's not tricky at all actually
make sure the tram gets over what oh
huh where
what
okay
i don't even know what to look out for
there i don't know what happened maybe i
went too fast
shy said there we go
oh there's a thing here and i didn't see
it you can't see it
but it's right there okay
why is it going upwards
no tram turn tram tram tram why did the
tram move
oh my god i can rotate it oh
it literally says it i kept trying to
use my thumb stick
oh my god
this is fine right it's better if you
don't rotate much better game if you
don't
there we go
okay first try watch this gamer here we
go
that's as i do it uh it's so easy oh my
god
just cut out all we'll just cut out
we'll just cut out all the
failed attempts which didn't happen
because they don't exist okay first try
let's go
[ __ ] you ball is it in it's harder to
rotate
i can't [ __ ] see
first first try first second try
my [ __ ] god [ __ ] you ball rotate
doesn't even help
i'm getting it
honestly why did the tram move i still
want to know i need
what
first third fifth try here we go
okay i've played mini golf and this is
the same
i got this
let's time it this time it i didn't time
it at all now i have to go back
or else i'm gonna it clips through the
wall
just look just grab a snack okay i'll be
done in a second don't worry about it
[ __ ] this ball this better be worth it
okay hold up time it time it there we go
okay i'm not i'm not i'm not even gonna
look i'm not even gonna lie
i did it so easy for a time
it's the ball uh
what can i blame this on my controller
it's uh i went too fast
i went too fast oh okay we didn't click
through the wall okay
thank you
stop
okay first try let's do this on that
first tryout
a lot of people get stuck on this part
not me because this
uh i know balls better than anyone there
we go
you just gotta time it here it's really
easy a lot of people [ __ ] up the timing
i have so much control really okay
why does this ball [ __ ] me what
[ __ ] you ball uh that was an obvious
glitch happens
sometimes i don't let glitches
uh bother me because
i'm not a child clearly
it's [ __ ] ball i'm still mad about
the tram moving like
50 attempts ago alright so here you just
gotta get speed
have confidence look how easy that is
here i don't [ __ ] understand
because i can't see
okay okay first try
this is so irritating
it's much harder than it looks okay
look how i timed that perfectly uh uh
too soon go for it
it doesn't react it doesn't [ __ ]
react
how am i supposed to time okay okay
how do i tilt it is this it okay
i'm never tilting it that's the key it's
the keys to not tilt it
i mean help the camera i mean
[ __ ]
okay this we go first try oh
a lot of people don't make it here on
the first try
go in please and then you just gotta
tilt it like this
it's easier if you don't oh my [ __ ]
god
i know nothing anymore
how does gravity work someone give me
the formula
asap oh that's why i didn't have it
okay here we go a lot of people fail
there that's cringe
not me
[ __ ] that
that was actually bad
[ __ ] you gravity gravity isn't even real
i don't believe in it
what yeah that's what i thought
going for it going for it
speed momentum go okay okay we did it we
did it
i don't know what's happening here i
have no idea what's happening did i make
it
i made it of course [ __ ] rotating
whoever told me to rotate
you you did this okay
now is the tram gonna move again why
does the tram move i'm clearly tilting
do i have to time it i don't get it
it moves on its own that makes no sense
go go go go go go go go go go i'm in the
tram
i'm in the [ __ ] tram [ __ ] you tram
now move me [ __ ]
what now what
oh i gotta tell the love that
eat my ass [ __ ] no i was supposed to go
there
where
all right easy part coming up here you
just want to
jiggle it in like that easy part here a
lot of people
it's fine it's all good
all right it's all good time it
perfectly of course
easiest bit coming up right here just
get it in there can't [ __ ] see any
why yeah it was in
this ball it's not a ball it's
like pig
grease dipped in time this perfectly
always always okay all right maybe
oh it's a centrifugal forts that's
pushing it out
a lot of people don't know about that so
i understand physics so i can do this
yeah all right let's see if we can get
this on the first try guys
you just gotta get the ball down here
and a lot of people filming this part
but
whether you just got time it a lot of
people don't know some people
uh some people flip it here but i like
what i like to do is [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you he ass
there's literally no obstacle here how
did i fail here last time
all right now we're at stop go for it
good
meh good we're in the tram okay we're in
the tram
where do i go where do i go from the
tram
where's the tram there's a hole there i
get it now i get it i just have to go
for it
i see it now okay we could just get time
it
it's got time to tram this is the
easiest part but a lot of people fail
on the easiest part cause they're dumb
i'm not dumb
go for it [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you tram never
see you again
[ __ ] yeah what's good
oh so easy oh my god people fail
at base oh my god they
never doing that [ __ ] again [ __ ] that oh
missed them
that's good to be a pro gamer and what
can i say
is everyone impressed
ethan could have literally just put the
[ __ ] ball in he just wanted to [ __ ]
same thing yeah
i got the ball baked well then feel free
to
i will air at the 30k
for all that for 30k now this is so
awesome
[ __ ] you and you're splurging
to hunger 30k means nothing to me do you
understand how rich i am
oh my god all that for 30k
get out of here buying all of it
buying it all
30k
30k good day then no it's nine
[ __ ] you all right v1
1k a try shut up shut up
okay we're good got so much done
so much done
looking good
yeah looking good
all right let's find some fish
is this where we need to go i think yes
the [ __ ] is all this then
[ __ ] ladders cancel
all right who wants to dying i've been
here are you serious
oh my gosh this is where i came from the
other way
[ __ ] lighters don't need them
all right the golden giant door with a
lock on it
who would have thought uh how was i
supposed to know
impossible for anyone to
just figure that out that's ridiculous
let's go
checking for loot checking for loot you
really are a tough one i know
no one gives me credit but i'm tired of
chitchat
time to die fine well you can hear it
pancakes
use a cheap turbo prop engine but he's
impossible to control all he does is
charge too much power output from the
reactor
completely invisible head-on invincible
but the dumbass managed to chop his
own damn arms up on the propeller also
issues with overheating from
running for long periods of time
conclusion a complete
failure okay so invincible head-on
all right
i wasn't concentrating on the the puzzle
pagan now
i actually was uh trolling you guys
to see how long people would watch that
god-awful day
now he cut off heisenberg's speech i
wanted to hear
um are we actually going here
this looks like a maze where he's going
to come through the [ __ ] wall i can
hear him
all right i i called it so hard [ __ ]
out of my way uh i actually have a
different reaction
jesus louise
uh guess i'll go this way
okay uh do the thing do the propeller
thing again
he's charging
so dumb you're so done
i don't like this guy
gonna lie he makes me a little anxious
ah [ __ ]
ouch
how many times the man gotta do this
am i supposed to
oh are we done
this is different
nope
[ __ ] i'm missing
ah we're overheating now aren't we
now that's new
okay
whoa he's crazy
bro cool it
can't [ __ ] see him jesus
oh my [ __ ] god
and now we should oh
hold up all right we're gonna have to
stun him or something
through the wall wall hacking dude
oh the flame [ __ ]
pancake right here bro
right here
oh my [ __ ] god i can't get around him
we're good now right
he's a [ __ ] tank dude
ah [ __ ] double one
triple oh gosh
come on we're so close
is it a trick bowl yeah
man you gotta relax
there we go no not too far what
i can't get around him
oh my [ __ ] god
oh this guy sucks dude
i just need one more shot i feel like
right here baby right here
maybe i should use another mine
i've been doing this for a while now
oh [ __ ] that's the flame i couldn't turn
around
did he not step on the [ __ ] mind
come here
was that it please come to that with it
now stay down
ah that last part took so long thank god
all right
got a little worry there for a second
ma'am look at this messy me rude
look at all this ammo i didn't pick up
[Music]
yeah okay
that's the last mini boss i expected it
to be a little cooler but it was still
fun and i went back
and you know we can chat we can chill
welcome
45 000 [ __ ] he was worth a lot of money
this is all an investment i know
that's how i look at it too [ __ ] we need
65k
how are we doing on fish john girl
used to be alive birth buckle
yes i can see why you'd be interested in
that
okay thank you for your patronage
uh i'll check the donut in a minute
or two
wait over here there's a goat while
going down the elevator
while going down the elevator
i don't feel like doing that i'm sorry i
really don't
they're too close to the end i'm just
like oh cigar
wow miranda is a bomb in a ball
her deceit knows no bound we're merely a
bunch of failed kiddo experiments to her
i was just lucky i had more affinity to
this stuff than the other poor schmucks
in the village
so she still calls me her son head she
can't see a difference between
experiment
and family miranda didn't just change my
body she took my virgin
dignity if i don't kill her then my life
will never be
my own still she may be crazy but she's
also powerful
she can turn into she can turn into
anyone using the mega miss site
the trick is that bright rose if i could
access her power then maybe
speaking of the kid's dad ethan has a
pretty interesting body himself
maybe i could get him to help me out
maybe alright maybe heisenberg not very
trust
this looks like a boss fight area kind
of
i'll loot them
i'm not saying it chad i'm not a
teenager
try someone else
perfect balance just like i balance that
ball you see that
boss fighting room nah
finding scrap room yeah no
neither there's a door there oh nice
tractor
i respect that what is the purpose of
this room this is so strange
it's us what the
ah that's the purpose of room
cut scene not bad
not bad jersey you're a persistent
but i've got a rebellion so stay out of
my life
we fight now
hey ethan i have a way better gun i
thought i sold that gun
to be honest
oh
uh huh
fat bastard it's a transfer
again no
this is so fish fish
there has to be prime fish
quality
yeah yeah
squeeze through
i told you to leave it alone ethan bro i
killed everything you've done [ __ ]
way oh am i dear chris oh am i
my wife you son of a [ __ ] you think i
killed mia
that wasn't her it was miranda
what uh chucker i knew it she's a bio
weapon
she changed her appearance and pretended
to be mia
seems she also survived being shot so
now i'm here to finish the job
i had sex with the bioware [ __ ] tell
me right away
because i knew you would want to be
involved and this job is hard enough
without civilians getting in the way
why huss chris
what the hell is going on
all right that's kind of cool all right
i guess i owe you an explanation
hand me that wrench
what the [ __ ] oh long story short
miranda's [ __ ] insane in this village
all these monsters and freaks this is
her life's work
some sort of crazy experiment with the
mold
the mold like louisiana
god damn it all this time i thought i
could save my family
i can't escape from here i can't do
anything
that might not be true
take a look at this my men sent those
pictures a few minutes ago
miranda keep looking
rose oh [ __ ] we did her dirty work men
are monitoring the situation
but they have my daughter you don't get
anything
you don't stand a chance against miranda
by yourself
i will stay down here and finish
planting explosives you take that
elevator i'll meet you topside
i promise you we will get your daughter
back together
damn straight will wish he was
heisenberg though but you know she's a
dead woman
i don't have that gun i sold that gun
this is freaking me out all right
i could sell the gun again and do me a
favor
try to stay under the radar yeah i've
been doing that i think we
i think we've been doing a good job of
that
can't turn back now can i get the branch
oh my [ __ ] god
yes
so close a closer written ending
must be very close hound wolf squad the
sweep of the factory is complete no
proof of any connection with the
organization
guess this just wasn't our lucky day i
did manage to get my hands on a number
of documents disclosing some of
miranda's experiments which support our
previous theories
she seems to have infected herself with
them
[Music]
which have has granted her a number of
abilities including
mimicry she can control herself and
transform herself to look like
anyone or anything i had sex with
body weapon that's an anime she
disguised herself as me and infiltrated
winter sees home her objective is
clearly to kidnap rose
maybe she thought she could control rose
easier if she
looked like her mom when we attacked
it put a little damper on her plants so
she mimicked the corpse
she then revived herself in the
transport truck killed everyone on board
and took off with bros my god things
didn't go the way
she had originally planned but in the
end she still got what she wanted
until now it's time to randy boo and
blow this place sky high
baby she might turn into this might turn
into a fight with heisenberg but i think
i found something useful
he left one of his little toys laying
around and it's even made from a
metal slash polymer composite which he
can't control
time to turn the tables
how convenient
all right right we get to ride
metal polymer composite huh time to
fight fire with fire
yeah this is an a47
polymorphism smaller pistol it's got a
[ __ ] chainsaw on it dude
what the hell how do i use the chainsaw
ready cannon
fire again guard
machine gun oh yeah
oh yeah it's all coming together baby
oh yeah all right
this is ridiculous and i love it
time to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] yeah i'm ready
blast the gator
which doesn't hurt me at all apparently
you're like a goddamn cockroach
this is the best
are you cool
oh
no we're living here
in the face of my steel glory
yes i do
oh hold up i did something
[Music]
[ __ ] i
accidentally paused my footage hold up
i hope i'm paused right now
turned into a michael bay movie
no i'm definitely damaging him okay
[Applause]
i can't hear
oh
the clock
getting the cannon
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh not in the beepies
oh jesus christ what the [ __ ] am i gonna
fight this
hey there's luke here come on
here we go the final stretch
well what do you think it's hopeless
right
this is
i blocked him it's all good
too bad i'm your only fan
he's not wrong
having fun nope
is he dead are we good
we're good right
i don't think he's dead i gotta be real
with you guys
[ __ ]
is he dead
i mean i tried but the game just didn't
let me i'm sorry
whoa i have the thing again that's so
cool
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah that was awesome
nice i didn't realize how many [ __ ]
grenade shots i had i was shooting with
a handgun
that's why you saved them i heard
explosions
what the hell happened toilet dealt with
heisenberg
now i'm going to find miranda and get
rose back not without me
it's too dangerous right there you hear
me
ethan rose ethan
why is it a bird you can respond why is
my baby a bird
shoot the bird shoot
[ __ ] our child [ __ ]
she's so important isn't she i don't
like it she's everything to me
i thought i had sex with a woman but
you're a bi what am i doing to me
with heisenberg on my own
what are you going to do i don't know
but i'm saving rose you'd never know
do you even when i took mia's place in
your home
poor ethan no you were definitely acting
like a [ __ ]
i could tell
i want a divorce
well that's so cool
remember evelyn and her power over them
all
rose is her successor no
rose is evelyn's true i like how you can
waste ammo like that
she will grow to fully control the
masses
and i must have her [ __ ] you you crazy
[ __ ]
ow don't ow the crows
calm yourself rose will be saved
the mega my seat catalogs all of us
however she will be reborn as
my daughter she's my child not yours
oh i thought the crows were on my side
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
show yourself why did rose come to be
was it because of her no way and you are
truly a special case
but i've learned all i can
your worth as a lab rat has run out
miranda you coward come on and face me
ow that really hurts don't
worry your death will come quick
you will join the mega my seats records
i need that i will make sure to sample
your blood
for later we put it back please breaks
the ceremony will be complete and i will
become
her true mother bound for eternity in
oh don't blood it
that's kind of nasty you're a nasty
[ __ ]
i've waited so long the dreams really
can come true
best or not i can't wait to see my
true child again
mm-hmm what the [ __ ] happens now
captain i've confirmed the death of you
no
no i wasn't able to retrieve the body
but i've recorded evidence
share your screen and i'll go over the
situation
my team and i were careless yesterday
we took down the transformed miranda but
we didn't kill her
who knew she could fake being a corpse
since miranda could have infected ethan
i forcefully took him
and rose with us
but the vehicle they were riding in was
attacked
when i got to the wreck ethan and rose
were gone
the last time i was able to contact
ethan
oh god i ate her food i ate her chore by
the veg lagunda
she murdered him and she is not
gonna get away with it did we get the
fish
oh now damn it when does it end
what's that sir the mission
all of it three years trying to put this
thing in the ground
three years too long
chapter two the fish trip
we'll get her for captain
so bsaa got here already they didn't
waste any time
mission adjustment no it doesn't change
anything
terminate miranda and wrestling are we
playing as him now or whatever
mission and failure's not an option
let's have some fun people
like old times move out roger
okay or this is the ending k-9
i want to know what the hell bsaa is
doing here find out what you can
roger that i'm on
this is the end we get to play cool
doing nothing but recon has gotten me
out of shape what kind of kind
of recon we know miranda's playing oh
sick bailey unless you play
[Music]
spooky this bloody spooky he took
five bottles of water to the head
while we do be what a giza
hey alba what's this
geez my i'll snort perfume over here
they've gone too far they've gone too
close tonight
ah christ they're fine looks pretty
rough down there
they're fine they're just landing on
reaching the objective
first we're gonna have to take that
thing out i've got your back boss
let's get to work everyone watch for
hostile bio weapons
roger can i shoot it from here
dead
made contact with a group of hostile
bioware
there's more than we thought
hell yeah only i had this gun earlier
this is amazing
love it [ __ ]
bsaa craft spotted two guards oh hell
yeah they give you all these kinds of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what's a target locator laser
targeting
why do i use that kara midnight
dude we're [ __ ] rich
what the hell is that thing it's all
new to my seat that's probably where the
rent is
let's go uh should we not nuke it and
just leave it to the bombs
this one
what do you got what you got
i'm fine i'm fine honestly
dude
oh loot
no look you kidding me
damn it the pat's blocked no worries
detour around the village
[Music]
oh my gosh
when i saw all whoa this is cool
when i saw all of them i thought oh are
they going to announce like a
co-op game or something at the sequel is
it
why am i supposed to go in here
yeah it's outlast now i don't have a map
help me i actually want the map now
oh no can't go there
cool
oh yeah i have so much ammo
[ __ ] you don't sneak up on me little
creep
um i need some backup i see you
200 to the point oh sure we're here
[Music]
stay dead [ __ ]
stay down [ __ ]
oh god
we're good
i didn't reload
they just want you to feel like a badass
after all that [ __ ]
okay
oh they're behind me no
hell yeah oh i don't see them
he died and gone to hell
that's right [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah stayed
dead again i've reached the target
location
damn this is big all right lobo marking
the target
could have done that from afar but you
know
nuke it
uh marking it takes a minute to target
the point
try and keep the laser on it as long as
oh it charges up
[Applause]
yeah well that [ __ ] the smitherino
reloading now just a minute
it's going to be a fight in the
meanwhile yeah
reloading be rejected soon
okay captain i'm reloaded ready when you
are
well i could have marked well all right
the mold is rapidly expanding did it
miss
i missed it i'm reloading
okay my horses are helped
ah jeez i'm not wasting these
you're right
how many are there everyone okay
oh that's the if the numbers are
increasing
we need to finish them off quick
don't do it
five more from the mountains east side
i'm nearby
which side is
round i wish i had more remain
sick it's them
ah [ __ ] me i should have saved my names
that's fine happens all the time
uh just a minute oh here we go
oh there's a red barrel right there fun
are they too big to get through i'll
take it
[ __ ] they're not too big they're not too
big
just point the laser at the target shut
the [ __ ] up
i need to get past and i can't
i'm a bigger tank than ethan dude
all right that was painful but i made it
oh my god it was one shot
are we done here oh [ __ ] hey
can i upgrade my gun faster reload
[Applause]
don't shoot me thank you appreciate that
jesus mate
it's cool i like it even though i suck
it's fun to play
[Music]
good mega micey must be below
uh-huh of course
[Music]
[Applause]
i found a way down i'm going in the rest
of you stay back
captain i compared the mold at the
village with a sample from the bakers
and
there's no sign of the genome editing we
saw in the e-series
the stuff originated here
oh homegrown nice
that looks like a big uh we're fine
i hear stuff oh there you go
no
hello
i got a tough guy here i'm going to need
backup
there's an opening in the roof use it
okay
uh five seconds
make it up here no am i supposed to just
keep
there we go
good i'll signal with the locator give
the guy a break
oh
he's really bad at aiming with that
giant thing
i could have done it
you got me
nice
he's still alive
come on you ain't so tough i killed you
before
i'm reloaded
let's get the flash bang
he's gotta be dead now please
i'm orange i'm orange dude
so if miranda was the fake mia where's
the real one i doubt she saw any further
use for her
i don't get any of this how did miranda
even know rose exists
a moldy little bird told her maybe we
can figure that out later
focus on the plant
it's the mega mice it's a giant baby
i had to try it out
out for the squad i've located the mega
my seat
so now we can end this mess after all
about damn time
is he's ethan gonna come back come on
i'm gonna go through all that [ __ ] two
explosives aren't
there's enough there to blow the whole
village sky-high it's like out of here
miranda ah i'm not taking any more
chances
i'm going in
captain i have eyes on miranda at the
ceremony site
keep your distance do not move until i
give the order
i know it's too late now but we really
should have told ethan the plan
there wasn't time we didn't expect
miranda to act so
soon even so you should have told him
yeah honestly yeah
this must be miranda's lap oh
a book okay
didn't it say examine for a second
okay subject name donna beneviento
affinity favorable brain functions
normal although severe mental illness
physically she is no different from a
regular human however
she can secrete a signal producing
substance which controls plants infected
by the muta my seed
when human absorbs the pollen from a
predictable flower she can cause some
type of hallucinations however
she's mentally underdeveloped and has
divided her kiddo among her dolls in
order to control
them from a distance an unfit vessel for
evil
be right back i gotta pee
yeah let me know when you
let me know when it's done
i would have normally stopped by now but
i want to see the game finished
so we keep going another book
heisenberg and incredibly favorable
his electric organs similar to the
electric ray narc japonica these
electric organs are connected to the
subject's nervous system
and therefore passing through
electricity through the entire body
allowing control of magnetic fields
which is used to move metal splendid
specimen but still an unfit vessel for
either
who's the vessel and
this is the puppet right
now okay regeneration rate is incredibly
fast so something can heal and external
wounds within section and grow her nails
mama in the claws in mere moments rapid
renderation also means increased body
size
hello so that's why the kink is there
due to hereditary blood disease the
subject must ingest human
flesh and blood on a regular basis to
maintain regeneration
properties i suspect that if the subject
regeneration is not properly balanced
then she may mutate uncontrollably
an unfit vessel okay
and the last one is blob
the simp uh low surprisingly low the kid
has caused drastic changes to internal
organs transforming them into organs
similar to fish like gills
and a swim bladder another subject with
a regular cell division
division causing him to transform into a
giant face the subject is unable to
control this
this transformation give me the defects
unfit best for either
cool
[ __ ] weirdo
oh that's creepy
dear miranda my deepest apologies for
not meeting you in person
allah nothing more than to visit your
quaint village once more however i am
incredibly busy
then again i suppose for an immortal
woman such as yourself you no longer
remember this poor half dead medical
student in the snow
i've always cherished the really
revelations i came to 15 years ago when
i stayed in your village i was inspired
by your research
to think one could transform a human by
infecting them with an organism
positively visionary i knew that with
that knowledge i could achieve my own
vision for the next step in human
evolution
even after two world wars and humanity
on the
cusp of another my conviction never
wavered
i realized however through the many
nights of intellectual talks you and i
shared that your conviction differed
from mine
you hope to bring back a single dead
person while i aim to change the world
your experiments on the mold would not
have aided me in my endeavor to achieve
an exponential infection i thought a
virus would be more effective
this is why my dear i had to leave you i
still regret never telling you
goodbye is this from one of the other
games
another person
oswald spencer like i i don't remember
it sounds like it
africa is clearly uh resident evil
5. my apologies for reminiscing i
actually have news that i or six
i thought my pleasi i found the key to
the evolution
the progenator a virus found in africa
i plan to start a company with friends
and colleagues dedicated to
virus research i will call it umbrella
just like the symbol
and the cave that we spoke about this is
cool so it's like an origin story
i'm one step closer to making my vision
a reality i hope you will
be able to achieve your goal someday too
you taught me so much for
that i will be forever in your debt
sincerely your
lifelong student also of e spencer
spencer here
i never finished my
i wasn't spoopy enough
really like what they did with the
series though in seven and eight
bringing back the stuff that people
really like
i think it's cool i really am i'm
pleased with this game
is that the real one show me your hands
um bryce this is alpha where is miranda
right now
whatever she's doing she's staying put
god damn it really is you
i'm glad you saved me why are you here
ethan's dead by the way i was caught
in houston experiments
in the flesh what's the situation up
there kind of
stick to the mission i'm headed to the
ceremony site it's a trap wait
oh you can't leave me here
damn it you said that you would keep us
safe
we did everything that you asked we
moved over here everything
and i didn't care so long as we were
together
so you tell me where is my husband
where is my daughter okay okay i believe
it sir
he's gone
i couldn't save him but i can save rose
come on it's not safe here after all
what do you mean he's gone he's dead
i'm sorry mia but we have to leave
we have to destroy this village no
you're wrong
uh-huh i tried to keep this a secret but
i'm pretty sure the village is destroyed
i killed everything you don't understand
how special he is
oh ethan ah
ethan's got us
hey nice
i had a feeling
what's going on
god i hate parts like this why am i
walking so slow
he's going to whisper stuff to me and
i'm going to go did i get here
oh god freeze
just [ __ ] my body
bro you don't have a heart
ants are fine at least that's good
you're dead
dad i mean
miranda she
no i still have to save rose
wrong it wasn't miranda
you were always dead
what are you saying i can still
epic dramatic moment i was wrong miranda
didn't kill you
[Music]
you mean you didn't think it was weird
cutting off your hands
no matter how much you got hurt
the fungus
three years ago the baker house
you were murdered by jack
what you died there
three years ago
that's that's it's awesome no way
you shouldn't even be able to walk
around
quit messing with my head
you shouldn't be walking
screw you
then what what happened
i did all that
think ethan
[Music]
how do you get it your whole body
is nothing but more
you can't ever see your family again
oh poor ethan
family
i have to save
my daughter you're already dead
[Laughter]
is it new
what now
i'm pressing ah we're in the back of a
van or something at last he awakes
where am i my carriage ethan you were
having a nightmare
it was all a dream duke
your battle with heisenberg was a sight
to see
oh thank god if we did that miranda
would show herself
how long have i been out not long till
dawg
duke i need a favor
take me to miranda i assumed as much and
i'm already on the way
what a homie the real g
man dude i thought but ethan
are you sure of this your body is well
falling apart
yes foolish of me to ask
speaking of foolish questions who or
what are you
even i can't quite answer that
we're here
i owe you one mr winters
i'm afraid you can't return to your old
world any longer
all right are you ready
this is really unexpected and cool i
like it a lot
i have to be
i gotta go
oh i still have all my stuff
cool
ah damon thank you so much
hell yeah i appreciate you man
appreciate all yeah
all right we're getting stocked up for
the last stand
sorry where ever supposed to go
not here not there not there
there clearly
can we upgrade the last time no
oh we can no [ __ ] way that's awesome
one lash for the road preparation is
more important
now than ever before oh that's cool i
like that they tell you
cool the cigar
a damp cigar should we keep it lucky oh
the assemblage of life and machine
i can feel lord heisenberg's essence
through it
do you have any fish
[Music]
hmm
please be well thanks
i just wanted to see how much ammo we
have on each one
as you wish
[Music]
yeah let's not forget about the magnet
i want to be careful let's maybe get
supplies first i
see anything else what is this
oh
oh cool
[Music]
i hope this one makes itself useful
your journey nears its end how about
some reckless spending to finish it off
oh perfect one moment please we
literally spent all of our money
save stations
[Applause]
oh what a beautiful last one
let's not forget the magnum this fight
is it me or do these resident evil games
just make sense so story-wise all of a
sudden yeah i feel that
first verse along here
now it's not the time my dude
oh my gosh dude
aim so carefully and then the lights
wake up
all right now we can walk fast
another one
oh i flicked them
stop wiggling please
how are you alive thank you
i was clean
i gotta keep going up
up up squeeze through
i know the gun is automatic why would i
waste ammo if i can hit the shots and i
got time
come to me
is that you she dipped it in the sauce
oh i've missed you
she finally did it
prophecy is completed cheers stephen
appreciate it man
my power is leaving me
rose
miranda
interesting your body certainly is
normal give rose to me
now you will see once i kill you
properly
yes
and you try to take it away from me
my desires will be fulfilled typical
women
you know what i mean i always take
babies and dip them in sauce i was like
you can't do that hey
cool boss you fulfilled your purpose all
right how do we kill you
you disposed of my false children and
awakened the glorious
now please do not worry
i assure you i'll provide her with true
oh [ __ ] i might die here i'm not letting
you get away
she became a tree
i need cover stuck
i'll take wonderful care
you understand the love
[Applause]
i shall put you to rest
this
[Music]
let's see some stronger
despair
it granted me this splendid power
yeah right all it's done is drag you
nuts
you're crazy [ __ ]
let me reload you be so kind
after all everyone dies
bye [ __ ]
okay cool
[Laughter]
now mr winters i think it's time to left
things in my house
my daughter will be made manifest at
last
i've waited a century a century
where the [ __ ] did she go oh she's right
above me
[ __ ] she has so much help
[Music]
she's my goddamn daughter
pancakes
i
all of them
i can take any form i deserve sure go
ahead
[Music]
no i'm out i can't craft more
oh my gosh
i've never seen a human live without his
heart
how much
ever think the problem might be you
miranda you're
not capable i don't have any magnum
shots
this is tight of real love
close i did it i think i did it
holy [ __ ]
to ensure i never see your face
get out of here with your long fingers
i upgraded this like 600 times
my daughter ours dry
just like the ball puzzle
you see that's how it's done pro gamer
hell yeah there are there's playthrough
the entire way through it felt good man
now let's see if she drops any fish
oh what the [ __ ] it's a baby
do you have any fish babies
[Music]
it's all right rose it's all right
oh i'm mold rose daddy's mold
ah ethan's hand finally bit the dust if
you know what i mean
[ __ ]
[Music]
ethan ethan where the [ __ ] were you
come on come on ethan wake up
the hand that was caught in resident
evil 7 molted away
chris ethan he did it
it's first cut up in this game too
finished each other
[Music]
nose reveal
keep moving ethan there's a bum in that
thing that'll blow this whole village
sky high
we finish each other look at me they say
that when i hit this trigger we can't be
anywhere near it
ah damn it me is waiting for you
she's alive you hear me alive oh mia
i'm so sorry i love you
keep rose safe hey
and you tell yourself come on it's not
that much further
watch over oh poor finger didn't you be
strong
oh he got the trigger goodbye rosemary
ethan
oh [ __ ] that's kind of badass
[Music]
for ethan man
come on we can still fight
[Music]
rose rose god i hear
go go take us up now
resting resting chad ethan
get moving we have to get clear no we
can't go not without my husband mia
sit down and strap in not before you
tell me where ethan is
he's dead [ __ ] i know he wouldn't
abandon us
tell me what's going on where
there right there in the middle of the
explosion
what was that i told you to sit down
where is he
chris really doesn't like to tell people
what's going on what have you done
he's gone i tried
he stayed so we could all escape
[Music]
i'm sorry
captain you need to see this
bsaa didn't send soldiers
this is a bio weapon what the hell were
they thinking
orders captain pick up the rest of the
squad
plot a course for bsa europe hq you're
it
oh sweden's next
someone's got to pay
he wouldn't abandon us girl he went and
saved rose and of course you want to
like yeah what the [ __ ]
hey we did it
[Music]
we finished it hell yeah that was
[ __ ] great
i loved it really fun game
i'd say it actually picked up in the end
even more right
it started off so strong with
uh jimmy's gear
that i i didn't think it would pick up
but it picked up in the end a bit
so i'm pleasantly surprised to be honest
thought it was
such a unique character it's really fun
all of them
it had some scary moments but it wasn't
there like
it's so scary but you know they've made
the gameplay fun and swell so
[ __ ] i don't know i'm not
i'm pretty pleased i thought it was
great
give it a strong eight eight point five
i don't know
there's a cut scene after the credit
well we'll have to check that out don't
we
[Music]
actually like excited for a resident
evil again after they deliver
these uh great games like i was saying
i just wish silent hill would also come
[Music]
back
thanks for joining on the stairs guys
that was super fun
[Music]
glad we played it
hope you had fun as well
[Music]
all this good to hang out play some
games
[Music]
what what
there we go wow end credits
she's got daddy's jacket she's all grown
up
do you think the little boy will be able
to touch the moon
nobody can touch the moon is too far
away wait what if he has a rocket ship
uh okay then you can touch it but it'd
be
very very cold
why did you have like a hearing thing
you were big
in santa monica what do you say senna
let's do it
it's going to visit daddy back in
louisiana maybe i don't know
[Music]
ah f's in the chat hey dad
happy birthday
you deserve better ethan sorry i missed
last week
you really did i have a lot of tests
coming up
you know how it is
[Music]
what the hell is he one of the goddamn
devil
duty calls
all right she has powers
yeah i found her where else
today of all days
we have a situation you're needed
evelyn don't you ever
call me that again oh oh it's just a
joke rose what a chump
i can show you things even chris doesn't
know i can do
we have a clear shot stand down
i can handle it she's just a kid
i want you to keep it together rose
you're a lot like him you know
i know
oh who's walking there
it's ethan
what was i where was i
the father story is now done okay
uh-huh took us 11 hours
extra content concept art figurines
challenges
uh the following movies have been ended
you now get a
following for example shop for finishing
the maze
it's total cp
what what is this
let's try the first one
i'm doing you see cool
all right huge bro fist thanks for
joining guys
that was awesome bye
you